dr. Tyson I want to do exactly what you
do what did you study to be where you
are right now
I studied physics and math both of which
constitute the language of the universe
okay in the same way you want if you go
to China you learn Mandarin you speak to
people there and you weren't Spanish to
go to Spain you speak to people there
right you want to speak to the universe
and understand what it's telling you
right speak its language and that's math
it's math and physics basically the
foundations of the sciences and so
that's what I did so I majored in
physics sweet in college and then got a
PhD in astrophysics and then you are
conversant then but I do these other
than write books and this sort of thing
so I think a lot about how people learn
and how they pay attention and so I fold
in what I know with what it is to share
that love then I'm just doing what Carl
Sagan said you do when you're in love
you want to tell the world oh hey if you
like this please remember everything
that we do can be found commercial-free
plus exclusive original content all on
Startalk all-access com